she's making this trade in Commerce
argument that is the year if Europe
doesn't arrive at a common distribution
system some unified system the very
commerce that undergirds the European
Union is at risk she's also making this
humanitarian argument that Europe has an
obligation to refugees and for her own
countrymen she's making a historical one
saying the Germans should be proud that
so many refugees want to come here when
you look at the numbers though they are
staggering this year 2015 there's
expected to be some 800,000 applicants
here in Germany it's very hard to make
this things from between refugees and
economic migrants now migration is
fundamentally of course a great thing
for Europe and if you look at the the
production projections then the fact
that you have more refugees will
definitely help Europe do to deal with
the problems that is suffering from it
so it's welfare states who are basically
going broke
when looking at the image that you see
in the media every day it seems that
these are poor people with very little
skills coming here to take benefit but
this is not the reality most of these
people notably was coming from Syria
people from the middle class they have
skills obviously they need to settle in
the European countries we need to find
them housing we need to album to grade
their skills and to get the language
skills we need a global strategy within
the global strategy in the sense that
that should imply all European country
and probably beyond but we need also
global strategy in the sense of an
elastic policy approach we need to
welcome people we need to fight against
smuggling networks we need to cooperate
with transit and origin country that was
more or less the approach that was taken
by the European Commission in May in the
proposal that is the right approach and
now Europe should get together and and
find ways to make that happen